House Democrats are on their way to an
extraordinary political clash with
President Trump launching a formal
impeachment inquiry it is the top story
across the country House Speaker Nancy
Pelosi says the president violated his
oath of office by directly asking a
foreign power the president of Ukraine
to investigate a political rival now mr.
Trump confirms they spoke about Joe
Biden but he says he did nothing wrong
he plans to release a transcript of his
call with Ukraine's president later
today this all started about two weeks
ago after the president's Acting
Director of National Intelligence
blocked the release of a whistleblower
complaint about that call now
congressional Republicans and Democrats
want to see that whistleblowers claim
Nancy Cordes is covering this on Capitol
Hill Nancy what does this mean for the
next steps in the impeachment process
what this means is that the Democratic
leadership is no longer divided it is
now all in on the impeachment process
and even the republican-led Senate is
now looking into this Ukraine
controversy voting late yesterday to
push the administration to release a
whistleblowers complaint it's really a
sad day for a country actually I feel
very sad about it after avoiding even
the word impeachment for months the
House Speaker now says Democrats should
quote strike while the iron is hot I'm
announcing the House of Representatives
moving forward with an official
impeachment inquiry the sea-change as
she put it came after president Trump
admitted that he pushed the Ukrainian
president to investigate unfounded
claims about a campaign rival former
Vice President Joe Biden there was
pressure put on with respect to Joe
Biden what Joe Biden did for his son
that's something they should be looking
at the actions of the trump presidency
revealed dishonorable fact of the
president's betrayal of his oath of
office betrayal of our national security
and betrayal of the integrity of our
elections now more than two-thirds of
House Democrats say they are open to
impeachment including members from tough
swing districts like Minnesota's Jian
Phillips I don't care if I serve one
term and
and do my job with the Constitution
foremost on my mind and the rule of law
I will retire or go on my way
recognizing I did the right thing
House Republicans called it the wrong
thing I realized 2016 did not turn out
the way Speaker Pelosi wanted it to
happen but she cannot change the laws of
this Congress and even Republicans who
have been critical of mr. Trump said
Pelosi should have waited I think she's
a bit ahead of her skis but let's see
what the transcript says let's hear what
the whistle blower has to say the
president insists he did not put a hold
on millions in military aid in an
attempt to pressure Ukraine but the
Senate's Republican leader says even he
was kept in the dark about the frozen
funds all summer I have no idea what
precipitated the delay but I was among
those advocating that we needed to stick
with our Ukrainian friends they never
gave you a reason I was not given an
explanation fortunately it finally
happened and I'm glad about that Pelosi
says she is now directing six House
committees to continue their
investigations but under this wider
umbrella umbrella of impeachment so then
what happens next well the House
Judiciary runs point here that's the
committee that would ultimately decide
whether to bring formal charges against
the president which would then be voted
on by the full house now that sounds
like a long process but Pelosi told her
members yesterday twice that she expects
the house to move expeditiously however
it's still unclear whether impeachment
even if it does pass in the house would
go anywhere in the republican-controlled
Senate where most Republicans not all of
them Tony still opposed it wherever it
goes we'll be following it Nancy thank
you very much